what will be the biggest stories of the
year ahead in 2020 the global economy
could tip into recession the trade war
between the US and China is one of the
biggest risks to the global economy 250
years after his birth one of history's
greatest composers becomes a global eco
warrior Beethoven loved nature and he
was writing for today and future
generations and the world's greatest
sporting event comes to Tokyo where the
inclusion of trans athletes could spark
controversy trans women are women I
think we need to race based on biology
done at that at that time there is only
one Beethoven in 2020 music lovers ears
will be attuned to the two hundred and
fiftieth anniversary of the birth of
Ludwig van Beethoven one of the most
influential and popular classical
composers in history
Beethoven broke the rules of music he
did things differently
take for instance his Eroica Symphony
Symphony number three how does it begin
with two massive chords it goes back no
one had done that before its Beethoven
saying look what I can do I'm going to
do it differently and he did that in
every form of music that he wrote in in
2020 across the globe orchestras will be
celebrating this genius and his legacy
with a string of performances and
concerts we doesn't do his music now
there's a tendency to think it came from
him fully formed it if you look at his
many sketchbooks and manuscript pages
their crossings out there are
obliteration there are tears in the
paper he struggled to compose and yet
it's what he did written during the Age
of Enlightenment Beethoven's music has a
history of being intertwined with
politics the opening motif of his fifth
symphony
[Music]
equivalent to the letter V in wars
became a symbol of resistance to the
Nazis and the final movement of his
Ninth Symphony became the hymn for the
European Union
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he believed in the power of the ordinary
human being that was who he was writing
his music for and of course we had the
great message in the choral Symphony the
final movement Schiller's Ode to Joy
which is all mankind will be brothers
alle menschen werden brüder it's a
universal message and in 2020 his
pastoral symphony will be used as an
anthem to unite millions across the
world to act against climate change
[Music]
they'd have loved nature there was
nothing he loved more than taking long
long walks in the country always
composing as he went waving his arms in
the air jotting notes down and that's
why the pastoral symphony is so
important in it in his output two
hundred and fifty years after his birth
Beethoven will continue to set the tone
for the future he wouldn't be in the
least bit surprised that his music was
so relevant today after all he knew back
then that he was writing for today and
future generations
so he'd probably say yep yep told you
told you
[Music]
2020 will be the year nurses received
the attention and treatment they deserve
the World Health Organization has
declared it will be the year of the
nurse a success
almost half of healthcare workers
globally are nurses and they are
increasingly taking on a growing number
of tasks previously reserved for doctors
most people have no idea about modern
nursing entails they think of them as
the sidekicks of her abductors nursing
today is a highly skilled profession
many nurses have university degrees
there are even doctorate level studies
in nursing in America two-thirds of
anesthetics are administered by nurses
and nurses in some sub-saharan countries
even carry out emergency cesareans
it's definitely a new level of autonomy
nurses in Britain are now trained to
perform surgery and are taking on more
responsibility for patients in
life-and-death situations with this role
it's going down to see patients on the
ward often by yourself
attending cardiac arrest calls and going
to see sort of the some of the sickest
patients in the hospitals
2020 will also mark 200 years since the
birth of perhaps the most famous nurse
in history Florence Nightingale if she
were around today she would probably be
concerned that a global shortage of
nurses will be the biggest problem
facing national health systems in the
coming decade by 2030 the world will be
short of 7.6 million nurses countries
will have to do more to recruit and
educate new nurses locally as well as to
retain those that are already in place
rich countries cannot continue to lure
nurses from poor countries where health
systems are already severely crippled by
the shortage of nurses Singapore has led
the way in addressing nurse shortages it
has successfully increased applications
from young people to nursing school by
commissioning dramas documentaries and
even a catchy pop song
[Music]
looking into the future nurses will be
even more important because so we have
more people living longer they require
more care a lot of health care
professionals at least partially may be
replaced by AI with nursing that would
be very difficult because it's hard
nursing it's healing powers are about
empathy and a human touch the games of
the 32nd Olympia are awarded to the city
of Tokyo in July twenty twenty billion
of people who watch the Olympic flame
burn once again as the Tokyo Olympics
begin but with new rules making it
easier for transgender women to compete
in women's events for the first time
2020 could turn out to be a highly
controversial in indie games there's a
heated debate in women's sports over the
inclusion of transgender women people
who are biologically male and identify
as women
International Olympic Committee rules
currently allow transgender women to
compete in women sports provided they
have suppressed their testosterone
levels for at least 12 months you can't
just ignore the fact that biology is
something that as humans we have but
some observers like former Olympic
swimmer and medalists Sharon Davies
argue these athletes will have an unfair
advantage you're not going to be able to
get rid of the male puberty that they've
gone through the fact that they have
male biology so even by reducing
testosterone for one year it's still not
going to level the playing field
but others take a very different view
like track cyclist Rachel MacKinnon who
has become a high profile transgender
athlete since winning a World
Championship in 2018 athletes come in a
huge range of shapes and sizes and
natural abilities population
demographics around the world are
different so Dutch women average height
is over five foot six Indonesian women
is around four foot ten so sport is
never level if by which we mean no one
has a competitive advantage over each
other because it's the point of sport
during male puberty testosterone drives
the development of bigger muscles with
more fast twitching fibers sturdier
bones and a larger heart and lungs all
lifelong advantages when it comes to
speed and strength the difference
between boys and girls running times
increases in adolescence and the gap is
even bigger for jumping events
and in 2019 among top athletes around
2,000 men finished the 100 meters more
quickly than the fastest woman Sharon
Davies believes there is a danger that
transgender athletes could dominate some
women's sports and that these sports
could once again be blighted by
unfairness in the 70s and 80s we had the
East German system where female athletes
were filled full of testosterone and it
made them unbeatable so for nearly a
whole generation the East German women
totally dominated in almost all female
sports at olympic and world level but
there many british that came fourth and
fifth and six and no one's ever heard of
them because they didn't pick up a medal
of which they should have done so I feel
quite passionately that I just don't
want to see that happen to a whole
generation of female athletes again
Davies and others who have voiced their
concerns have faced strong criticism
from the transgender community and
beyond you have been called by the
transgender cyclist Rachel McKinnon a
transphobic and somebody who shares hate
speech
McKinnon argues the debate is
fundamentally about equality and human
rights both on and off the playing field
inclusion a fundamental principle in
society so I think that applies also to
sport that applies to intersex women
cysts women and trans women that to be
considered fully equal members of
society to be respected in our
identities is to be included in sport
for who we are and trans women are women
the IIC says it actively supports both
inclusion and fairness it was due to
announce stricter guidelines for
transgender athletes in September 2019
but so far it's panel of scientists have
failed to agree on what these should be
I think we need to race based on biology
so I think the very simple
straightforward way to race is based on
your chromosomes and if you carry a Y
chromosome which gives you a benefit a
wide benefit and male benefit to your
strength levels and your testosterone
levels then you need to race where it's
apparent so we would should have an xx
female category protected and an open
category which is then inclusive for
absolutely everybody that wants to be
able to compete so I just think there's
ways forward but doesn't mean the
destruction of female sport while
countries will be competing to make
their mark on the medal tables the 2020
Olympics could also prove to be a
decisive moment in the wider global
debate about gender identity
[Music]
in 2020
the possibility of recession were once
again hangover the world economy thanks
to one thing in particular the trade war
between the US and China is one of the
biggest risks to the global economy and
it could be enough to tip it into a
recession the u.s. increased tariffs on
200 million dollars worth of goods China
striking back at the u.s. today stained
it will raise tariffs on 60 million
dollars of US goods we saw an escalation
in the trade war between the US and
China the start of 2019 and after months
of confrontation China and America
agreed a preliminary deal at the end of
2019 to mean that complicated but that's
what I do it's a phenomenal deal but
details are scant and there's likely to
be more back-and-forth in 2020 we still
don't know how that's going to play out
business confidence is low and there's
been a synchronized slowing over the
course of 2019 around the world and in
2020 one of the biggest losers set to be
caught in the crossfire will be Germany
Jerry's the motor of the European
economy and its really been sputtering
for the past year in the third quarter
of 2019 it very narrowly avoided falling
into a recession Germany's very exposed
to international trade and as a result
is particularly vulnerable to an
intensification of the trade war in 2020
Germany relies more heavily on trade
than any other major economy its exports
are worth almost half of its GDP and
much of that is manufacturing exports he
on a global company based in Frankfurt
is the second largest producer of
forklifts in the world
American tariffs on Chinese exports have
affected the company's sale and the
continued uncertainty is damaging the
company's ability to plan for 2020 and
beyond today you have a tariff tomorrow
maybe not where should you make your
next investment and so if you're not
sure of how competitive is this region
going to be what do you do you wait why
do you do it someplace else
[Music]
in 2020 the chilling effects of the
trade war could spread further than
manufacturing the fear is that an
intensification of the trade war and a
potentially disorderly brexit could mean
that the troubles will spread from the
manufacturing sector in Germany to the
rest of the economy which so far has
been insulated from the pain if a
recession looms in Germany the
government may have to change its
traditional habits Germany has a chronic
underinvestment problem the government
has a rule which means that it cannot
run a budget deficit in 2020 if the
economy continues to do badly and
unemployment starts to rise the
government might find itself forced to
break the rule and to spend more to
stimulate the economy
and if the malaise spreads globally
other governments may also need to
loosen the purse strings
the biggest story of 2020 will be
president Trump's bid to be re-elected
as the leader of the free world we're
going to keep making America great again
mr. Trump's re-election hopes depend on
him winning in the States he took from
the Democrats in 2016 he will probably
take Ohio and Iowa again and possibly
Florida too
but Michigan and Pennsylvania may return
to the Democrats and this means that one
small state in the Midwest could be the
most fiercely contested Wisconsin if
Donald Trump wins Wisconsin again in
2020 it's highly likely that he'll end
up back in the White House for four
years
the reason Wisconsin is so competitive
is in many ways it's a microcosm of the
country like in other states the big
cities Milwaukee heavily Democratic as
you move further out into the outer
suburbs they get more Republican until
you get into the countryside when you're
into solidly Republican territory since
1984 Wisconsin has voted Democrat in
every presidential election until 2016
Donald Trump will carry the state of
Wisconsin this is truly the beginning of
the end for Hillary wins campaign in
2016 Donald Trump on the state by a
narrow margin of just twenty two
thousand seven hundred and forty eight
votes I won Wisconsin and I liked
Wisconsin a lot Henry Clinton famously
didn't campaign in Wisconsin in 2016 the
Democratic nominee will not be making
the same mistake this time around
in 2020 Democratic candidates will ramp
up their well-rehearsed attacks on mr.
Trump his policies we have a guy there
that is literally running our country
like a game show his personality in this
president you have somebody who is a
racist and his failures the president
felt free to break the law again and
again and again
but baiting the president and his record
is unlikely to be the key to setting up
a Democratic victory in the Badger State
that will probably hinge on something
else
voter turnout on the election night
itself
the thing to watch for will be whether
turnout in downtown Milwaukee is high
which would help Democrats whether it's
high in rural areas and the outer
suburbs which are predominantly
Republican who wins the presidency will
affect billions around the world but
that outcome may depend on who turns up
to the polls in a state of just six
million people
thanks for watching if you'd like to
read more of our predictions and
analysis of the big stories of 20/20
click the link opposites and if you'd
like to see how well we did last year
predicting the big stories of 2019 click
on the other link and don't forget to
subscribe